esports highlights last forever people
always want to celebrate the greatest
plays of all time but that also means
that they're always going to be there to
remind the people involved of their past
for better or for worse being in a clip
that gets shared over and over again can
be one of the things that could make a
player famous
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's going to hit the ground
there's cold oh
wow that's jumping double cone what is
going on right now how does he do this
even if that moment is uncharacteristic
or a one-off or even something they'd
later get revenge for controller fingers
turned to twitter fingers damn you
getting money
but for north american fighting game
master justin wong the past is all
around him all the time and it's not
always good renowned for his game
knowledge rock solid fundamentals and
never say die attitude justin won
championships in multiple titles and
built a legacy that'll last as long as
competitive fighting games well there's
just one
little problem the biggest clip in the
fighting game community and maybe in
competitive gaming history shows justin
wong getting absolutely destroyed oh
i'm pretty sure a lot of people started
fighting games because of this moment
a lot has happened since justin lost
that round but even after he grew up had
a kid and even became a content creator
that one moment has always followed him
oh he got it you think he got it bro you
think he diego you ain't daigo
oh i go he i know
he diego
so who is justin wong really how did evo
moment 37 changed the public's
perception of him and how did he change
along with it and why is he spending his
time getting parried by randos online
with names like oroville redenbacher i
know you want to get famous bro come on
tell me tell me do it yay back up
oh my god no come on it's 20 20
now you cheated
all right folks before i tell you all
about the incredible legend of justin
wong i've gotta ask you to please sub to
the channel if you haven't done it yet
we are really really close to two
million subs and if you subscribe and
turn on notifications you could help us
get there okay so the justin wong of
today is pretty different from the
teenager who was grinding marvel vs
capcom 2 in new york arcades in the
early 2000s maybe you know him because
he's a purveyor of hot takes the kind of
tearless maestro cinnamon toast crunch
i actually think it's whack i actually
think it's overrated i actually think
you guys are tripping on the internet
maybe you know him for popping the
sickest barrel roll when fighting a
mystery or maybe you know him because of
the whole evo moment 37 thing we'll get
to that in a moment and i always tell
people that i'm the ken player
emotional damage
most people probably think of justin in
a pretty positive light these days but
that wasn't always the case justin has a
long and storied career and it began
when he was basically a kid genius for
fighting games in new york he went on to
win a world record nine evo titles
across three different games he also
racked up some incredible comeback wins
which led fans to create the idea of the
wong factor
[Applause]
oh my god but the weird thing is that
despite all of his incredible
achievements for most of the esports
community many of whom don't even care
about fighting games at all justin's
name will forever be tied to a single
moment in the losers finals of evo 2004
whether you first saw it on a dusty crt
monitor in a school computer lab in 2005
or on a modern smartphone more than a
decade later on one of our top 10 lists
the climax of evo moment 37 literally
starts with the words
let's go justin
[Applause]
daigo's full parry of justin's ill-fated
chunnely super art and third strike was
probably the first truly viral esports
clip and remember it went big before
social media sure the internet existed
but evo didn't blast out this clip on
tiktok and instagram instead it was
shared countless times on forums by
content aggregators like ebomb's world
and on meme dumps like ytmnd and it went
viral because it is legitimately an
insane play it's really crazy that the
first hit you have to do before the
flash
like my man have you had the tap board
before the super comes out
so how how did daigo
knew that i was in the super dare
look at oh my god why is it before the
blast but listen i promise this video
isn't just a deep dive into
evomon37 not really this video is
actually about how that moment changed
justin wong's life and the course of the
fgc because in 2022 as justin went hard
on youtube he experienced that moment
over and over again
oh this this is a familiar stage
this is very familiar
let's go justin oh [ __ ] no okay okay
now to be fair even right after it
happened in 2004 justin wasn't totally
crushed by this moment far from it he
didn't even really consider himself a
street fighter player his true love was
the marvel vs capcom series even getting
as far as he did at evo 2004 in third
strike a game typically dominated by
japanese players was both a personal
achievement and a huge moment for north
america you know going through the
tournament uh you know i i fought a lot
of japanese players and you know i'm
going through them one by one
and you know
it was feeling good i felt like i had a
lot of momentum right and then obviously
daigo just stopped that with the parry
and just two hours after getting hit by
the most legendary parry in fighting
game history justin walked over to the
marvel 2 tournament and absolutely
destroyed the competition but justin
wasn't just a literal punching bag in
moment 37 he was also kind of hated back
then for being so good at fighting games
so he was the enemy he was the bad guy
right um people didn't like him well i
mean they liked him but he was always
the guy that you know west coast wanted
to lose and i was like he was the guy
that you wanted to see lose at nbc2
because he kept winning right you always
vote for the underdog justin was the
east coast golden boy so his rivals on
the west coast were talking a lot of
trash their jab at me was saying oh
you're just a marvel player that's the
reason why i would say i started
branching out on other games because i
wanted to prove them wrong
that i can play like other fighting
games that's not just marvel's catcom 2.
it's probably not fair to say that
justin was widely hated or something but
especially marvel 2 people didn't love
his defensive turtle style and how
willing he was to play for time everyone
knows me as a lame
player
you know i like to wait the time out
always goes to zero or something
and it's true i love playing lame by
2004 he was facing plenty of criticism
and the west coast fans in the evo venue
were actually cheering against him in
favor of daiga justin's decision to
throw at a blind super was also
criticized after the fact even though no
one had ever seen shun super parried
like that on the big stage you know this
is kind of like rumors of like oh yeah
like no one could parry the super it's
impossible to pair you know you know you
have like those little silly rumors um
so that's why i always thought in my
head that the super cannot be parry this
is an instant guaranteed chip damage
because pairing all those hits it just
seems impossible but while evo moment 37
has remained an important esports
highlight maybe even the most important
the narratives around it have changed a
lot over time for one thing as more
people were inspired to pick up fighting
games whether because of the clip the
release of street fighter 4 2009 or
something else the average level of play
in the fgc has risen for one thing a lot
more people can do the diago pair right
now between the internet being a better
teaching tool for fighting games and the
fact that people have had 18 years to
practice it there's a lot of fighting
game players out there who can just do
moment 37 at home i mean fighting game
pro ryan hart can do it without even
looking
[Applause]
now to be fair it's still really hard to
do this if you aren't no lifeing third
strike i mean look at our resident fgc
boomer josh trying to pull it off
i'm going back to mmos and even justin
tried his hand at it recently one two
three four five six seven one two three
four five six seven
yes
you see these days justin doesn't enter
as many tournaments he's a dad now and
he spends a lot more time creating
content for youtube that means he also
spends a lot of time playing classic
fighting games online for his content
where he inevitably runs into people who
have done nothing but play third strike
for the last 10 years and can do moment
37 with their eyes closed
oh what
my man
that's crazy bro
2022 was just l's for me a lot of these
insane clips were huge on twitter and
they just go to show how iconic evo
moment 37 is and just how much the
public perception of justin has changed
over the years justin came out the other
side of eva moment 37 a hero he remained
committed to the fgc despite all the
criticisms of his decisions in that clip
his play style in general and anything
else about him when he and daigo met in
evo 2009's grand finals justin
transformed even though he didn't win
he was the home crowd favorite and that
turnout for evo 2009 was like huge a lot
of people showed up like you know a lot
of spectators a lot of fans a lot of
people that just wanted to try out evo
and play the tournament and the same
thing happened to marvel 3. people loved
him for playing a team that many saw was
sub-optimal and that didn't stop him
from pushing on
i'm not even gonna i'm not even going oh
my god
[Applause]
so
once
it came down to like where there's
actual fans and not just players now i
would say that's probably kind of where
the image of me has changed because you
know there's a lot more fans now after
2009 that was the first time evil
streamed the fgc tournament was was that
event as well too he might have played
lame sometimes but he clearly cared
about winning about the games he was
playing and about the community these
days justin is a hero to the fjc and
people recognized his role in evo moment
37 as something that helped the
community survive
see if you don't follow fighting games
it might surprise you to learn that when
daigo parried that super third strike
was considered a flawed game that was
running out of time street fighter 3 was
a really technical complicated game that
was missing a lot of old favorite
characters in street fighter 2. it
didn't really bring in new fans herring
may have been hype
actually scratch that parrying was hype
[Music]
but it did distort the game in some
notable ways and while evo moment 37
probably wasn't the only reason that
fighting games survived the tough times
it was a huge help it revolutionized
fighting games in general because when
that happened everyone started playing
fighting games more seriously again
especially third strike because dirt
strike was definitely a dying game in
america at the time until that happened
and that's why justin keeps running into
these randos online they're inspired by
esports greatest moment to make him
relive his tragedy oh he got it you
think he got it bro you think he diego
you ain't daigo
oh i go
i go hit that i go
but for justin it's all worth it not
only because the moment gave the
fighting game community something truly
special in the past but also because it
can keep doing that it turned out that
when a huge portion of the world saw how
awesome fighting games were there was
another game and a new generation ready
to revitalize it that couldn't have
happened without third strike without
the moment and without justin i know a
lot of people like they know of b they
know justin wong but there's so many
players out there that a lot of people
just never heard of or don't know or
just never even paid attention about and
that's kind of like my goal is to kind
of like showcase that there are other
like really great fighting game players
out there besides like the ones that you
probably know from google right so you
know they're not like household names
but like there's a lot of killers out
there and so for the rest of us
we're gonna keep trying to parry it
because in some small weird way
we get to be a part of that moment we
might not be daigo but for a moment we
get to relive that feeling of seeing
that incredible clip for the first time
it cuts to the very essence of what
fighting games are all about and as long
as there are people out there willing to
be tested justin is probably gonna keep
sacrificing himself to give them the
chance
like why am i so scared of that right
oh my god no
oh okay that doesn't count that doesn't
count that doesn't count
perfect
it's just like the the the speed at
which he's saying tatsumaki
is like
impossible to understand i never knew
what he was saying for until like street
fighter 4. it was also just like the
real thing is that i need to i need this
sound board that is just like all the
times he says countries where he just
goes england
[Music]
ussr